george's governing party the georgian
dream wasted no time in claiming victory
with results overall giving it a 47
share of votes cast
georgian society has once again given a
proper response to the political forces
thirsting for revenge which threatened
our state with violence and unrest
but the leader of those political forces
was emphatic that they are on course for
at least a few upsets
[Applause]
today we can freely say that the
georgian dream has completely lost the
capital the political center tbilisi is
lost and we can already say the city
council will be staffed by opposition
parties
that's not the case yet a runoff is
expected the chance for the united
national movement georgia's largest
opposition party to win an important
prize
four other big cities will also go to a
second round
[Applause]
the sudden return to georgia of exiled
former president mikhail sakashvili and
subsequent arrest may have energized the
opposition
convicted in absentia of abuse of power
while in office sakashvili has said his
charges are politically motivated and is
now on hunger strike
he and the rest of the opposition wanted
these elections to be a referendum on
the georgian dream government
they did not get the decisive result
they were hoping for although election
observers have noted many instances of
fraud and intimidation
government misuse of resources may also
have tilted results in its favor
georgia's western allies have grown
increasingly concerned that the
political parties here must start
settling their differences in the
interests of their country
the outcome of this election suggests
voters want the same
robin forrester walker al jazeera
tibilisi